oubliez les propos rassurants des
propriétaires de pipelines au pays s'il
faut en croire le rapport d'équiterre la
sécurité des oléoducs est déficiente et
ça dure depuis des années des problèmes
d'ingénierie des problèmes de suture des
pipelines qui sont exposés aux éléments
en 2010 est seulement il y a eu 173
incident au pays une hausse de 122 cas
par rapport à 2016 au québec 55 % des
incidents enregistrés depuis 2008 sont
survenus l'an dernier et ce sont les
citoyens qui dans la majorité des cas
les ont découverts sans compter que les
systèmes de détection des compagnies ne
fonctionne qu'à moitié
le pipeline trans nord vieux de 60 ans
qui transportent des produits pétroliers
du québec vers l'ontario est
particulièrement visée sylvie rose on en
sait quelque chose il y a deux ans elle
constate qu'un tuyau qui passe sur son
terrain est à découvert au dessus d'un
ruisseau qui s'écoule dans la rivière
des outaouais
l alerte quand ce nord l'année suivante
la compagnie des verts du gravier sur le
tuyau
on sait aussi que l'érosion sous la
tuile hausse est là qui fait que ça et
qui perdra des casseurs parce que le
tuyau est plus soutenu depuis rien n'a
été fait trans nord pour ne pas la
nommer a eu 79 avis d'infraction depuis
si moi j'avais 79 avis d'infraction à
oka au code de la route
j'en ai pu permis conduire et je serais
probablement prison que peuvent
continuer d'opérer en toute impunité
c'est proprement scandaleux québec prend
la nouvelle au sérieux
ce qui est dans le rapport s'avère il va
falloir qu'il ya des gestes soient posés
la compagnie trans nord a réagi par voie
de communiqué et déclare nous évaluons
continuellement nos systèmes afin de
nous assurer que notre rigueur
opérationnel et adéquate
tandis que l'office national de
l'énergie rappelle que ses inspecteurs
vont continuellement sur le terrain pour
surveiller les activités des entreprises
mais ce sont ces dernières qui sont
responsables de la sûreté des pipelines
pour équiterre
il faut agir maintenant la récréation
est finie
nous allons travailler très très peur
s'il faut nous allons aller devant les
tribunaux pour faire respecter les lois
et les règlements au canada bref selon
équiterre l'application des lois et des
règlements fédéraux et provinciaux
en ce qui concerne la sécurité des
pipelines est un échec ici catherine
kovacs radio canada montréal